[Música]
hola bienvenidos a enlace andino hoy
desde colombia soy santiago lópez
gonzález en el programa de hoy
hablaremos de los controvertidos
resultados de las elecciones
parlamentarias del pasado 13 de marzo
que no han escapado de los señalamientos
de fraude y que han puesto en entredicho
el papel de la registraduría general de
la nación que es la entidad encargada de
organizar los procesos electorales en
colombia hablaremos también de los tres
candidatos que resultaron triunfadores
de las consultas interpartidistas que
fueron celebradas junto con estos
comicios parlamentarios además
analizaremos como la elección de estos
tres candidatos configuró el panorama
electoral definitivo de cara a la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que están previstas para
el mes de mayo bienvenidos
[Música]
cerca de 39 millones de ciudadanos
colombianos estaban llamados para
participar en las elecciones
parlamentarias para renovar las dos
cámaras del congreso colombiano estaban
en juego 108 escaños para el senado 6 de
ellos corresponden a las curules
especiales para la paz pactadas en el
acuerdo de paz de 2016 y otros 188
escaños corresponden a la cámara de
representantes
el pacto histórico una coalición de
partidos de izquierdas llegó al senado
con la mayor cantidad de escaños 19 en
total aún así no tiene mayoría y deberá
hacer alianzas con partidos de centro y
de derecha los tradicionales partidos
conservador y liberal obtuvieron 15
escaños la coalición alianza verde y
centro esperanza 13 escaños mientras que
el oficialista centro democrático pasó
de ser la primera fuerza política en el
senado con 19 curules a ser la quinta
con tan sólo 13 en las mencionadas
consultas interpartidistas fueron
elegidos tres candidatos que se unen a
un total de 10 aspirantes que disputarán
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo mes de mayo al igual que en el
congreso la izquierda aglutinada en la
coalición pacto histórico liderada por
gustavo petro quiere llegar al poder
para hacer así el primer presidente de
este espectro político en gobernar este
país suramericano
en la otra orilla está en las
condiciones tradicionales de partidos de
derecha como equipo colombia cuyo
candidato federico gutiérrez recibió el
apoyo de óscar iván zuluaga el candidato
del oficialista centro democrático
también en este grupo se encuentra el
candidato independiente rodolfo
hernández sergio fajardo quien aspira
por segunda vez a la presidencia es el
candidato de la coalición centro
esperanza y busca fortalecerse por medio
de alianzas según las encuestas
recientes los candidatos mencionados son
los más opcionados en la intención de
voto para la primera vuelta presidencial
el pasado político de colombia marcado
por la violencia por una guerra de más
de 5 décadas y también un proceso de paz
que está con una lenta implementación
hacen de colombia un escenario único
para estas elecciones presidenciales por
eso para realizar este tema hemos
invitado al analista político camilo
granada que está con nosotros señor
granada gracias por estar con nosotros y
comienzo por preguntarle por la
configuración del congreso mayoría de
escaños para la coalición de izquierda
esto es histórico para la cual para qué
significa si señor es la primera vez en
la historia de colombia que una mayoría
de izquierda o el partido más importante
de esta izquierda pero también es
importante resaltar que vamos a tener de
todos modos un congreso muy partido muy
segmentado con prácticamente 2
mitades casi iguales
de izquierda y derecha hubo denuncias de
fraude durante el proceso de conteo de
los votos hubo señalamientos por parte
de diferentes partidos políticos y
diferentes sectores de la sociedad
colombiana esto qué significa esto
genera incertidumbre entre los
colombianos y entre los partidos
políticos bueno yo creo que todos que
separar las cosas en dos lo primero es
cierto que afecta en la organización de
las elecciones fueron un fracaso y el
responsable de esto es el registrador
que no supo organizar las elecciones
afortunadamente y por ahora lo que es el
escrutinio sea los resultados de la
elección a parecen ser menos
controversiales pero sin embargo es una
señal de alerta importante frente a la
importancia de fortalecer el sistema
electoral en colombia que sigue teniendo
muchas deficiencias ya están
determinados los candidatos que van a
participar en la primera ronda de las
elecciones presidenciales después de
esta consulta interpartidista conocimos
a los tres últimos como queda entonces
el panorama general para las
presidenciales bueno yo creo que tenemos
una una elección en la cual tenemos un
candidato de izquierda muy fuerte un
gran arrastre que lidera en las
encuestas y el resto de las opciones
partidas me explico en el centro está
sergio fajardo pero también está en plan
cultos hay dos candidatos y en la
derecha está federico gutiérrez y esa
figura un poco extraña que es hernández
que uno no sabe si es muy bien de
derecha o izquierda es un populista que
puede quitarle votos a ambas partes
entonces lo más probable es que vamos a
tener una segunda vuelta y en la cual el
candidato izquierda gustavo petro va a
estar presente en la segunda vuelta
falta por determinar quién de esos otros
cuatro va a ser su contendor en la
segunda vuelta señor canadá muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
el enlace de france 24 usted muchas
gracias estas elecciones presidenciales
tienen lugar en medio de un alto
descontento social la pandemia de kobe y
19 sigue causando problemas en la
economía colombiana según las cifras
oficiales 21 millones de personas están
en la pobreza y las cifras de desempleo
se espera alcance el 11,8 por ciento
para finales del año en curso siendo
estos dos temas cruciales para esta
elección presidencial los colombianos se
preguntan cuáles serán las propuestas
que harán los candidatos que esperan
gobernar el país desde la casa de nariño
es todo en esta misión de enlace andino
soy santiago lópez gonzález sigan con la
programación de france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]